Good morning, John.
This is part of a series I'm calling vlog extra days in April, which I hope you will join me...in...
Weird, weird, what is...
There's a, uh,
little guy here. [Laughs] I think I accidentally just found a geocache. That's exactly what it is, and that's gross.
It looks like there's some gross stuff in there. I'm going down to the river now.
It's more of a creek, or as they say in Montana, "crick". I dunno why.
Ooh! It's pretty.
I'm basically just coming down here to find a nice place to film.
So hopefully I will find one of those soon. I'm pretty good.
Make sure my butt crack isn't showing.
So I wanted to do something that no one had ever done before, an adaptation in online video.
Taking a previous work  and transferring it into this new media.
There's not...I don't know of any examples of this happening.
I wanted something that was a great story that I loved, and I wanted to make this kind of something that my wife would really enjoy.
And I wanted something that was very dialogue-based and very character-based,
so that we could do it not as a big production with lots of sets and scenes and everything,
but just as a person talking to a camera.
It's a work of fiction,
adapted into a video blog, and the work of fiction that we chose is Pride and Prejudice,
because, you know, it's the best story of all time. Such a wonderful romance and the characters evolve so much,
and I'm so interested in the—in this story, and I never would have been if it hadn't been for Katherine of course.
But she's a huge P&P fan.
Basically a scholar.
Its much, much different than anything I've ever done. When I make a video blog like I prefer to be alone, right?
This is like resting on a tree right now. Whereas this, you have to have actors and, like, a sound guy and
production people, and writers, and organizing all these people, and that's something that was totally new to me.
And also like making a story, 'cause—'cause I feel like Vlogbrothers is a story, but it wasn't intentionally a story.
We didn't set out to like, start here and end up here and have a middle. It's wonderful story, it's my favorite story ever,
but, with this, we're actually telling a story, we have to figure out how to break it up, and how to write it,
and how to transfer it into the present day, because obviously it's not a period piece.
It's really new and really exciting for me to do something that-that's so different,
and of course, like, I don't have time for this, but here I am doing it anyway,
because I was just so captured by the idea.
And it's also important to note that it's very different from what I'm doing, and
thus it—I don't really know how to get it out there. There's part of me that's like, I know this is good...
so what do I have to do now to actually get people to watch it?
We've made eight episodes, and to make more than eight episodes we're going to have to, you know,
somehow prove that people want to watch it, so either we can get a sponsor
or we could just get enough views that we can pay for it.
It's pretty, you know, honestly dangerous because it's very different from the way that any other,
uh, fiction story has been told before, so it's entirely possible that it just will not be a good way to tell a story,
and I hope that that's not the case,
I don't feel like that's the case,
but it-it's possible and that people won't react well to it.
If you don't like it that's fine, and I'm not worried. It's-it-it's...I consider it to be an extremely exciting experiment.
So that-that's how I'm feeling and I hope that, I hope that you like this...straight up
I hope that you like it.
I hope that you enjoy it, and if you do, please share it, and hopefully, we can make this a sustainable project,
and we'll get to tell the whole story of Lizzie Bennet, and Mr. Collins and Charlotte Lu...
Charlotte Lu, she's called Charlotte Lu in the show. Charlotte Lucas in the book.
Now I have to go to a dinner party with some friends of mine.
And now I'm home.
Hey! That was a lovely dinner party. Look what my friend Dan got me.
[singing] "Troy and Abed in the Moooorning!"
I'm gonna put an annotation up, so you could check out Lizzie Bennet Diaries,
John, you will see me tomorrow because I'm vlogging extra days in April. DFTBA.